well that's annoying hey hey what's up
we're back second episode of Resident
Evil 7 that's correct
playing the game that we set out to play
from the very beginning 9 10 months
behind schedule but thanks to everybody
for joining I'm like Mary do you guys
want to find out what that noise was
what's the menus really recap you know
do you member what happened last time I
went to go find my gf
yeah yeah uh Mia she was in a house she
was locked in a cage but she was cool
with it yeah then she like turned into a
weird person and tried to hurt me so I
had to kill her with an axe to the dome
you know I killed her back up after you
actor Oh in the dome yeah no no you shot
her up in the attic and then Jack Baker
knocked you out right I asked her to and
she that was before she shot her anyway
I think it was her dad tried to feed me
some human parts
I met the family and then I don't know I
did some puzzle solving but I think it
all culminated with me the officer came
oh the police officer came and the guy
shelled him through the back of the head
and then I shot him to death in the car
while he was trying to run me over
mm-hmm and I think that's where we ended
it I don't know you got the you got like
this bronze bull thing there's a drawer
and I needed both halves and I got it
yeah did we get to a checkpoint I don't
really remember right yeah you went back
to the laundry room it saved cool okay
so that's where we should be at
continued I'm excited and we figured out
the brightness this time it was kind of
dark at the beginning of last episode
right right right we were gonna there's
a few things you missed couldn't see
everything all fairness there's a lot of
things you can miss in this game it's
not like oh like is after goodies no not
good at like just a little like you
could see someone walking past a door
certain points that's way yeah that's
cool I told you that the garage fight
can play out in two different ways you
can get in the car or he can start
running you over I both times I could
not actively run him over in the car got
in the car and he pulled you out the
second time right are you saying that if
I get in the car what happens do you
like you can actually run him over
ah that's cool but then he remember he
said I got something beautiful to show
you or something and then he took your
gun and shot himself in the face right
it was pretty beautiful I mean you're
into that [ __ ] it's pretty like a pretty
broad use of the word beautiful but I
will tell you I've been playing a lot of
not great resi games and that opening
was incredible it was scary
it had like really good atmosphere I
felt it like I was intense
I think the gameplay was pretty solid
like both a mix of puzzle-solving
killing dudes killing my girlfriend like
had all the things I enjoy yeah it's
definitely strong I'm sorry I've always
described it as like resin evil one in
first person remake the fact that you're
in this mansion and kind of in a
secluded setting going back and forth
almost Metroidvania a long load times
normal good thing we have good banter
just kidding uh yeah it should be I
don't know this is long it's a long load
I just really wants us to stare at this
food pile fantastic feast gross but yeah
I mean I must admit like I I was going
through a bit of a slog where I was like
crap I gotta do like like play my
Resident Evil six but it's like I look
forward to playing this I mean I'm
excited to play this yeah with you guys
gonna watch him okay rooms
oh right with my save box so you
remember you can combine chem fluids
with gunpowder to make bullets or herbs
to me we're saying I have to choose
between ammo and health for now you
start to get more options later but
remember if you press r1 it goes to a
much more handy combined screen right
yeah your wrists stapled back on so
another interesting thing oh yeah I got
my wrists stapled back on I want to show
you something
that you also miss you saying you missed
is weird because everybody has a
different experience in this game right
I know it's cool but like a little
exclus you got me a nice little tidbit
that I would all right where am I going
just when you go back on the main hall
okay so you remember jack was kind of
chasing you around this part of the
house yes but he shot himself in the
head so yeah so walked toward the bull
door to your left the bull door the door
with the key in it oh right yeah so if
you're if he sees you and is chasing you
around he can kool-aid man through this
wall right here on the right and into
everyone yeah so then a it scares you
but B it also makes a loop you can do to
get back into the basement so you didn't
see what yeah and then and then he chops
off your hand and you can it shows you
putting the liquid on it so basically
that chem fluid stuff you're using is
like this Miracle Grow that connects
your limbs back together hmm I think
that's cool I wish I would have seen
that I was hoping you would just so
would scare the [ __ ] out you but you got
a few other scares how did I so I just
didn't catch me the second time correct
also remember those bobble heads you can
shoot those as collectibles or knife em
or whatever you want to do yeah I would
knife it I don't know if I have a knife
though so I think if you get enough of
them they unlock I forget what do I have
a knife yeah do I have a melee
laughter right on your it's set to a
quick hotkey I think I'm left her right
on your d-pad on the d-pad sorry there
you go
where's that Bob down at the end of this
hall table
yeah you kind of hear them
there's also one in the laundry room I
think I forgot where you can get it
later
you'll probably be back around here
here's your body horse math puzzles
solved Oh Lord
can I get in that box is that your idea
of beating the game just hiding that box
forever
oh no I don't want to go in there oh
this is so Petey makes you like hate
picking up phones oh good it stops what
a weird place to play poker look I know
this is like such a small thing but that
fan with that light makes it look like a
head is walking by and so that's just
like super calculated like that's not an
accident like nobody like didn't
consider that I was meant to make me
uncomfortable
Oh what's good my god
oh my god
I [ __ ] up I broke the cardinal rule
Indiana Jones that pretty hard remember
remake when you take the shotgun too
early the spikes on the ceiling start
closing in yeah yet should I put it back
oh also you have the car keys in your
inventory still I don't think you need
those you can so I need a know what you
need yeah I don't fake gun to put in
there or at least something of equal
weight thinking along the right hi-ho
silver away you're not far off actually
your dumb joke is actually kind of close
to are those car keys not wearing khakis
are those the car keys okay okay I see
what's going on here guy hunter I need
an Eagle shaped item no problem no
problem
sky hunter this is New Orleans there or
this is Louisiana their Eagle stars
everywhere okay cool so I just need to
find an eagle
captain Howell told state police
reporters Helen Midkiff
like midriff then there's a been a lot
of people missing in the last few years
well I feel like that could be it okay
so I need a scorpion key gross oh damn
it didn't I give you a hard time that's
your father who used to be I'm sorry but
he he he said he's dead now you just not
be able to pull this off what what else
there's something I need you to do but I
can't explain it right now you may need
some sort of keys to do it but find a
way out of the house okay I'll be in
touch damn it so that's Zoey she might
reduce herself before there were the
reporter lady that said she would help
me not my girlfriend she say she's a
reporter I made I might have made that
up know kind of over near the door you
came in through that you didn't read the
bobblehead is on top of it oh yes thank
you
oh the bobblehead was saying okay
nevermind ooh recognize that our clay
mountains that's where there's people
one two three reckon cities in the our
claim oh that's nice little throwback
there's this I bet you that's a lot you
have the ability to do that Oh should I
go up these stairs I haven't gone up
here yet oh my god grandma Ruby's here
oh my god you [ __ ] suck no she's so
old she's all teeth I'm just impressed
she has to you oh my god [ __ ] off oh my
god I hate this woman [ __ ] this place is
Hugh was that noise
honestly if this was that Marguerite
that's the mom right yeah was she doing
all right well I don't know what all
that's about can't really do much so I
guess I'll just like let her hang out a
friendly reminder you can destroy those
boxes with your knife you did it in the
garage that was a week ago there's so
much to this house
okay Jimmy can't help you keep busy all
right so I can't open this oh my [ __ ]
god
what was that how paranoid should I be
at all times in this game I love that
like windy sounding remember you kind of
know where you are now
that's a garage door down there remember
you saw this stairway you're like holy
[ __ ] was that there all the time
don't drop down there you can drop down
oh is it hard to get back up you'd have
to go all the way back right it's a
shortcut to know it's there but yeah I
would I would kind of keep exploring for
now Oh gross okay there's a weird
bathroom tub right in the middle no I
remember this from previous things yeah
this is a throwback at the remake as
well
yeah like zombo's always come out of
that [ __ ] oh is it
Eagle shaped you can inspect them I like
those things
oh right you always used to teach me
that I should know that I should know
better
poopy somebody pooped out this point the
shower Jack's got a sick car but Danny
sucks at digesting coins that's a rough
one yeah I'm nervous
me too all right well it was relatively
[Music]
so [ __ ] beat the hell out of dying
she's got a really weird this garden
home I feel like I'm not running enough
you do tire out the family is only part
of her gift he's fast he's too bad
shut the door the door didn't shut I
haven't been in this room before wait
does he not know where I am
[ __ ] Missy in this rumor is the outside
he's out yeah I try to keep it this way
sure you wanna shut the door
no no I'll shut the door I don't I think
they'll just make noise there's
definitely stuff up here to explore but
I think you're better off trying to well
I'll let you play whatever we it's
there's not like a right thing to do and
well there are a few right things to do
in this situation but there's nothing
like specific you have to do yet you can
do a few things oh my god that was weird
how do you know can you hear him oh you
know what no I can't yeah again [ __ ]
you're right oh my [ __ ] god just hang
back here I don't know hi peep remember
there's no button to block l1 maybe run
get the [ __ ] out of here
where we go I don't know back to the
main hall you got that wooden statue
thing does he go wherever he wants he
[ __ ] he's not done I don't think oh
my god he went around the bar without us
seeing him like he can come in here um
I'll tell you after just right now do
the wooden statue it's gotta be this
thing oh this is hard
that looks kind of like a bird [ __ ] yeah
that there's the beak okay okay it's not
the best controls it's kind of like
trial and error okay okay I feel like I
got it
but it's backwards a horizontal flip oh
[ __ ] sorry
nope okay there we go now horizontal
yeah there you go Oh usually have to use
the right stick for that's weird nope
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay is that a
little bit how close do I have to be
relatively just get rid of those gaps go
to the left on the other stage so wow
that was cool oh I'm hurt
as someone who builds this oh god I was
there someone who I will tell you when
you're doing those puzzles if he was in
the same room as you and knew where you
were it wouldn't let you press X on it
to do it but if you're kind of in like
in hiding or whatever and he doesn't
know where you are it'll let you do it
in time outside of the puzzle will
freeze at least on this difficulty for
future reference
but like escaping him is he actually
kind of dealt with him pretty well
except for almost dying yeah well [ __ ]
shut up you really got using I thought
you didn't help me at all what am I
gonna say do something valiant well I
was gonna peep which means I would have
seen him but you were like what's that
noise but you were like no you're good
just sit here sit tight Mary it's like
[ __ ] hid you didn't look this is a
cool house if it wasn't so like decaying
I'm not over the last incident
so yes are you blaming me I don't feel
great about it
tensions are high fluid oh I'm full if
I'm all this Kenzo it's really filling
me up um
Shay don't need the car keys tonight I
could just dump them right yeah no no no
no I don't think you can I think you
just took chem fluid yeah boobie head Oh
actually just for a little teaser peek
through these the windows are the little
slots on the side of the door yeah see
that thing right there oh that's like a
gun of some kind yeah a machine I was a
that pushes bullets out of it another so
it's a crow double-headed crow and you
just touched it you probably have avian
flu now
what a poor crow Raven not to Raven oh I
need those items so you have two options
well you don't you have more than that
you could go back to the laundry room
put stuff away and risk running into
jack or Marguerite or Lukas right am i
close to one another one I say or you
could keep going in here and kind of
just again keep in mind you're gonna be
backtracking in this game I'd like to
just go and get rid of stuff I know it's
not the cool thing to do but I prefer
that because it risk finding again I
just like would like to save because I
think we've accomplished some yeah you
don't have limited saves either right on
this mode okay Oh God it's kind of like
God if he's out here
yeah keep in mind you're not at full
health but you can probably worry about
that when you get to laundry I thought
he was gonna cool a man up no I really I
think [ __ ] in there god damn it alright
so while you're in here there is a
bobble head I can hear it but I don't
know where alright um okay so keys yeah
I should probably heard of a couple
slots um I could probably get rid of I
don't need all this Kemp Luud right this
is the point do you want me to just let
you figure things out you want me to
give you any tips or what
I could probably combine right I could
combine excuse me why don't I hit r1 oh
I can't do that in this stage
you could okay so I could make Oh a
minute why can't I you can it just says
you have zero right oh I think I should
have one of these okay at all times make
sense you can't make anymore you can
make bullets too as well actually well I
know you can't you don't have another
herb I don't think yeah you you have two
more never mind so my health is green
but I have red stuff in my vision what
does that mean I think you'd have to
take another head before you get into
like caution yellow yeah okay so should
I make another herb or do you think
bullets are more important right now so
that's the cool part of this game is you
kind of have to it's a risk/reward thing
you might be better off just saving
these ingredients to see what you need
down the road okay I just like want to
have more open slots is what I'm saying
yeah yeah I was thinking about like
maybe putting these away oh wait join me
the coins I haven't used a coin yet
let's say you could store those for now
and now opens up three slots so I'm
pretty happy with that I want to keep
the tape because I want to watch it but
I don't know how with that guy there
well you're closer you're closer to the
it doesn't have to be a TV in the bar
where you found it could be any TV so
there's one right near you right now Oh
finest bobble head it's annoying me I
think it's in here might be in the
crawlspace under you but I can hear it
look back to the other side of the room
and I think it's underneath you oh it's
down there to your left
sorry I actually didn't know that was er
I just heard him it was annoying people
so wait are you saying there's a TV in
here no it's the one you originally oh
wait oh no that was in the guest house
that was the intro nevermind Jamaica new
save data yeah so you do have a clock
pendulum in your inventory they saw that
I'm ringing a bell
well no pun intended yes there was a
clock out here that didn't have a thing
on it
should I do that now oh my god I hate
this they're doing such a good job at
keeping me afraid let's say if you kind
of like that it's not like zombies in a
specific spot it reminds me can you come
in here you can't come in here Wow
coffee's not helping with this game this
is like Resident Evil three guys just
always [ __ ] around
can't come in here I'll tell you people
can't come in to save rooms on this
difficulty and I'm not seeing discredit
you because this is the normal
difficulty
well he's outside yeah you could use a
crawl space come on safer that way
you're gonna come out in the room with
the trapdoor holy [ __ ] I love that he
said boo and it actually scared
if he's yeah I done crouched before you
actually get out I'm lovin right there
what was that
the trapdoor okay
oh my [ __ ] god he could not have been
more casual right please come on don't
come in here oh my god it's just walking
around with whatever that is like a
mallet with nails and I think it's like
a garden hose but yeah it's definitely
not
it's definitely modified he Dead Rising
that thing yeah I can't I can't yeah you
should delay the clock thing is this see
this is where the hole in the wall would
actually commit handy I wouldn't go back
down there you're just gonna go back to
the save room and have the same amount
of ground to cover but that's up to you
I mean I guess it's safer than I can't
get rid of him like what am i doing well
you could stealth around him and go back
to the main hall because he's not like
in the main hall right now he's on this
side of the house or you could shoot him
in the face few times if he does chase
you this is ridiculously I don't think
he could chase you into the ER it will
not go away I don't think he could chase
you into the narrow crawlspace pass the
eagle trap door get out so that if you
get there like go back to where you were
before here then you should be fine
relatively
maybe I'll just run me if you're not if
you don't alert him I just stay quiet
and walk
please don't do that thing where you
jump to the wall he's too fast I feel
bad that I told you about that now but
it's still kind of heighten the
anticipation okay now you got a loop
yeah gianna loop you just go back to the
evil jook jook jook jook yeah sprint I
am screaming slow yeah just go back to
the Eagle crawlspace where's that past
oh right even wait [ __ ] lady too no
oh
soon is Marguerite and precious no it
really was him
yeah you should have told me psycho yeah
I you bumped that up I slightly
anticipated others geez
alright so okay so tape that the plan Oh
actually you can get those pills on the
table now that your wait oh right to
open this I can't open anything pills on
the table oh [ __ ] I shouldn't I'm sorry
whoops yeah so if you pop those things
they'll kind of highlight things in the
room for you what the pills yep sorry
wait where was the other way out okay
right yeah I'm dumb sorry here's here's
a general tip for this whole game make
sure you scrounge every no possible yeah
man this looks like Picasso
vacationing husband and wife the husband
was a success he's the 12th
unfortunately the wife was no good we'll
just get rid of her you can press X so
it comes up on the screen oh thank you
college girls avoiding the ex they're
all rotten homeless man turned in three
days he's the third teen so turning is
like must be something they do to say
that people and turning them into those
like dead oh that's rude is there
nothing in there
under them pretty gross though eating oh
I touched it stop touching they've never
seen maggots like swarming a trashcan
I've seen maggot yeah like a compost bin
it is really [ __ ] gross they're all
the victims alright I feel like I
scrounged this room pretty good I've
touched most every I forgot he could do
the kool-aid thing past the intro
alright stop bringing up is this a new
room I don't remember this room
oh wait what's happening oh my god is
everything this [ __ ] game kill you
how do i heal r1 regenerate l1 boy hold
that one quick yeah okay if you think
they're about to swing or you could
shoot in the face either one works is he
I think you should I can't remember
I'm trying member feels like Resident
Evil member the earlier ones where you
kind of waste I wonder if he's like
healed again now that he went back
oh right like I [ __ ] it up I should
kill them you might want to kill it if
he comes out he might not even come out
show yourself
oh okay so I went into this new area
right yeah this is new what is this that
there's that you walk I think it's me
walking on gross [ __ ] does it kind of
look like the upside down yeah
don't have one of those oh sorry
try the handle you're on the other side
of this door oh right
oh I'm bleeding try the hand you have
for sex I don't know I stink nevermind
you need the key
[Music]
I've seen that payroll
when you're in a creepy house it's
you're excited to go down there aren't
you
you're saying that last time this game
is good about like making you drugged
doing things yeah here we go
super Oh a same room I love this ad so
much mm-hmm that like for Lauren kind of
nostalgic Louisiana horror twang I
really need a lock very specific niche
genre those bastards are looking for me
but maybe this gives you a chance to
escape to escape you have to find the
relief shaped like dog heads I saw one
of the heads in the dissection room
underground get out it's the key out of
here okay so she left this for me
[Music]
dissection room that's not creepy okay
so I'm full health I think I got 26
bullets which is pretty good I could
make a health potion good you yeah I
have an urban if to herbs
and I have gunpowder in case I need to
make a thing but I'm almost out of
chemistry check the desk next to you
just to see what the item is so you're
not nor near the favorite words you're
right it's not Oh God shitty guide
[Music]
sharpens the senses making item
detection easier alright that's about it
I'm gonna save cuz I'm here
good idea uh yeah I'm stressed out I
feel like I'm sulking in my chair
because I'm like everything has killed
me I hope it's locked
be locked be locked that's gonna have a
dude that's gonna be a dude these are
all dudes isn't it that's these are all
dudes [ __ ] off he even told me to guard
oh my god I'm so dead I didn't buy huh
come on plug when he attacked you
oh yeah just I like the future typeface
though and that you are dead yeah that
looks nice oh my god so so I have to go
past him to unlock the door from the
other side how much how much guidance do
you want here because I do have a few
tips I can give you but I don't want to
ruin anything
we've already died so okay I would
suggest not going to the basement yet
okay you will it will be easier if you
wait a little bit and do some other
stuff okay I'll just say that see what
happens
oh these are the molded yeah you have to
take off their heads completely or
completely tear their bodies apart kind
of like dead space or just regular
zombie shots got it
Oh was that the same one from before I
don't know that there are specific ones
that's just mold you know you see it all
the time you work here I know you see it
yeah I've been playing Rainbow six a lot
lately and they do that so they just
regen every once in a while is that what
you're saying well no I'm just saying I
don't I don't know that I was like the
same one check is my so you could do the
grandfather clock or you could have
Explorer upstairs a little more that
piques your interest there has been
nothing good that I found today like
nothing you are just running into
problem after problem toilet there's
something in the other one too it was a
coin I think oh oh that's the story no
look if this house was nice it's like a
district or we're like secret passage
I'll just a random door yeah it's just
sweet how it's just the people living
here that suck and the mold
you know Tim Terry over Capcom he
pronounces it mold dead and that might
just be Tim it's definitely just Tim oh
yeah so if you were to pop those
psychostimulants it would show like hype
things highlighted through walls oh cool
not forever but like a few feet around
each do you think I should do it I'd
save it how many drugs do I get I think
it'd give you one for now it's not
enough dress
all right so upstairs to play the tape
or the pendulum or just exploring
upstairs in general
Jack kind of sidetracked you he sure
[ __ ] ditch well I just want to know
where he is so I can be in the other one
god damn that all right you could figure
out how to get the shotgun why I thought
I needed like a shotgun I will say that
if you do the grandfather clock you
don't have to go to that side of the
house all right let's do that let's do
that let's do it but I will say I think
that's where you last saw stop saying
but I will say I think that's where you
saw Jack before it is where I saw Jack
before but it's been a while try I will
say you might die sorry is there another
way to get there I have to go this he's
got the hole in the wall now that'll
help you loop him if you need to all
right play call of duty zombies a lot
might be a second
with that oh you can Marguerite's good
China
that's silverware I think I might have
made the same joke last episode so far
so good
this game is better played with
headphones oh my god yeah get that [ __ ]
Oh God
that's [ __ ] trick go back to the car
yeah yeah get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
go
run you dick hole I run so badly yeah
that was my chana into the hole wait is
he following yourself he's behind you
I'll give a [ __ ] hole safety hole can he
come in the hole o'clock I really [ __ ]
you over but you got the dog head you
got one of three the Cerberus thing to
get out of the house
wait I'm not even out of the house
wait still the house how far no no you
could earn up I browned the phones oh he
said you need three of the dog heads to
get out remember that door I remember
the back door there's the safety room is
it in the thing it's past the basement
down the toilet yeah but there's a guy
in here well like I said it's not every
time he comes out but there's potential
good god Oh what no no you're fine I'm
definitely saving no no that's fine I'm
saying don't I thought you were gonna
put the dog head in the storage crate oh
you think I should keep it well it
remember it's kind of like the early
games where rather than store stuff in
the box and then later on have to have
three dog heads in your inventory
you're better off putting it into the
door so you don't don't worry about it I
don't even remember where the door is
it's in that poker a big living room
near the phone that you talk to Zoe
please don't please it was still there
god [ __ ] [ __ ] back oh I'm always scared
I've always upset I've never not upset
like resident evil 3 did this so well
because I was always afraid he was
following me
yeah I was what is he here no you have
to tell me if you can hear him tell you
that no I don't hear I have the doors
kind of you can see it right now what
door to put the dog in there's a graham
I still owe that fan is the grandma stop
it no she's gone oh [ __ ]
where is he no I actually don't know
whether you technically make less noise
if you're crouched
is that you walking or is that him
that's him but I don't
he's either right above you or in the
like west wing or wherever you started
I think he's far away how do you know
could you hear him way more stop moving
is that him my nose whistles I think
it's just you and the steps are a little
bit yeah I just go for the door but the
dog's name oh my god I [ __ ] hole
safety hole can you pull you out safety
hole no vacancy just like I like mine oh
my god
I'm [ __ ] trapped in here okay you
need the Scorpion key to open that door
to make another way through all right
what should I do he's in there there's
really not a lot I can do in here no he
might wander away
[Music]
try the door again what doors get just
to get rid of the dog head
I just saved so you can make a run to
the door then come back to your safety
hole pull me out he never pulls out God
bless the safety hole
where's the door tear right near that
phone yet
sure
doc no doc gods I'm sorry there's stuff
you could do upstairs I don't know if
he's up there or not but you should try
going upstairs let's give it a whirl
oh there's another staircase oh yeah
I've never been up here on this side
yeah she did
wait what year was that 2014 that's
pretty great that's actual animals are
stapled and nailed to it not emblems
yeah actually I don't even think I
processed that before oh my god the
decent chance Jack's gonna be in the
upstairs corridors but I'd still say
this is where you should go right now
you could do the tape in the bar and
just in general explore what was that
who's that who's too fun
oh-ho-ho sweet sweet hole listen I know
this so I know what you should be doing
right now let me let me ask you what do
you think you should be doing right now
hanging out in the hole not now now but
like future near future I should play
the tape in the tape yeah it's a little
game or dip and
oh [ __ ] no you can't
I need like a thing that replaced the
shotgun when all right you're gonna like
what I have to say I'd say you should go
to the basement now you specifically
told me not to go to the basement yeah I
did you know you don't have to well I'm
not doing anything over here I guess you
can go to the basement if you want
please don't have a moss man you ready -
I'd have health ready okay
bossman
molded
Jesus all right so I only have one chem
fluid so should I make I don't so bring
the herbs and the gunpowder's cuz I'll
you think I'll find one
oh wait I have to Kim so I can make why
don't I make both like right now I'll
make one I don't know if you need
bullets yet you have like 11 that's not
a lot no that's your that's your reserve
you your gun is also loaded though with
more because I've 18 I'm gonna make one
of these yeah I would just wait now yeah
see if 21
oh I should save sorry
let the outsider from dishonored in that
photo I feel like I should have eaten
like I don't feel good I have like a
headache and are you sick are you
alright I like I think I'm just like my
stomach hurts from like getting weird
all the time
alright so so you killed that other and
molded you did a good job so they're not
in any way indestructible
they're just potentially numerous in
this mold infested basement yeah this is
should I maybe just run past him or
should I kill him what kind of player
you are I usually just try to kill them
wait them out that one might not be
around this corner anymore I did it I
thought they took more bullets
honestly I keep moving though got it
yeah unlock this [ __ ] here right what's
the green just unlock it I think go back
I think it's a you unlock that
I don't know what this is hold on go in
it door D or right you can unlock of
this yeah there you go so that no hon go
through it I don't know if you need to
go through it or not now you've got the
loop back to it that's where you started
okay okay okay are they in here can they
hear me oh yes okay I got my first key
Oh God
treasure photo I should go lockpick
scorpion keymap run don't don't wait
bullet just go let me lock you up
July yeah now get the [ __ ] out of the
basement yeah save room alright good a
lot of progress okay might not feel like
it
why wouldn't been let me say alright
scorpion keys really big the maps
probably gonna help little bit and that
treasure photo you can get some good
stuff Oh merci games scary you have a
lockpick now so you've run into a few
lock things you can open specifically
the drawer right behind you if you want
to okay so that is like a secret or
something
I hid something nice here try to find it
if you can
yeah also you can unlock a drawer behind
you now if you want oh or the lunchbox
does it does it work lots of times or
just something it's almost time use yeah
so obviously go find other ones but
that's I honestly I don't remember
what's in this as opposed to that lunch
box in the other room so you might as
well just do this while you're here
this one yeah I can't believe it's one
time you're not Jill Valentine master of
unlocking lock-picking sorry [ __ ] I
should save now that's it
you got the Scorpion key the treasure
photo dead inside oh my god I love the
way the mold had peeled off the wall
they're horrible creatures are you done
you go make you gone yeah do you think
they're here I don't think it's like
it's not scripted well I mean there's
spots but it's open
yeah but remember oh actually yeah now
that you're you got Sakura Miki oh wait
the door my thing is totally full well
hold on oh yeah you're right
I don't think you need the treasure
photo with you I've seen it yeah
remember what it was
look like it looks like a fireplace at
this point you I don't give you the
gunpowder and you have a help I don't
think you need that chem fluid or herb
unless you get really [ __ ] up and also
those psychostimulants those are better
for when you really want to make sure
you're all right so I'm going upstairs
well no well yeah but hold on turn to
your right you cannot make a new loop oh
that looks so tasty and we're back here
so that's a good loop to have now you
don't have to go into the safety hole
all the time damn this is a brilliantly
crafted game
[Music]
what was that noise so you you can get
both the treasure and the shotgun right
now oh you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] let's
just play this out make your move
friend oh yes nope check out the stairs
yeah actually this will be a really good
time if you can get by him right now oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god where you gonna go
you [ __ ] oh okay yeah play this out
until he goes back to like the East Wing
or whatever it is you swing I'm just
calling it that come out come out
whatever you are ah [ __ ] that doesn't
really solve my problem do you oh you
saw you he saw you safety halt safety
hole oh yeah you're onto me well check
this out squish it's probably like where
does he go
god damn I told Lucas to board up that
safety hole
god bless this safety hole I can use my
little secret nook now yeah go in here
[Music]
oh right oh yeah what are [ __ ] inject
them and check it out really yeah you're
telling me to use steroids right now
it's through yeah you'll see trust me
hover over it will tell you dramatically
strengthens muscles and increases max
health effects lasts indefinitely
yeah it's like a permanent much just
like real steroids huh I'm not
complaining yeah yeah it's a permanent
upgrade might as well just that's
amazing your pee pee just got so small
that's okay I'm not using it in this
place no horrid joke sweet steroids
[Music]
don't have anymore lockpicks to you he's
probably gonna be here just go upstairs
and just [ __ ] stealth around well I
just go keep in mind you instead of a
safety hole you couldn't go through the
scorpion door and I don't know what
he'll chase you through there at the
very least it'll be quicker than waiting
in the safety hole every time hopefully
you've now stairs right now I mean we
will find out soon
[Music]
oh geez he's definitely ok stay upstairs
yeah yeah yeah yeah now upstairs front
hallway does that mean my GU he's after
my Google I can't lose him right yeah
you can
he did see that no scorpion door [ __ ] I
don't think he knows where you are
listen grout you might be right don't do
this again we've been here before
married he doesn't know where you are
you'd like [ __ ] off
no he definitely doesn't I'm saying but
don't hide here forever because he will
find you
yes scorpy door oh there's chalk gun in
there yet [ __ ] cats now just [ __ ]
Oh like this
yeah keep in mind you could drop down
stairs into the East Wing I thought you
told me not to do that oh you can I'm
just saying earlier before you were
exploring so but that's a good like
escape
I think you awesome I'm so wrong sorry
you'll I got the right idea though oh
sorry sorry I keep forgetting I'm doing
such a [ __ ] job just trying to lose it
sounds obvious I know you're already
doing that but he's fast
scorpion door well I think you lost him
yes oh [ __ ] quick no no why'd you had it
you had it cuz you said he was fast yeah
but you've lost him he didn't seem okay
he doesn't wear your eye right now Shh
go slower he could be still in the
billiard room can you check your health
I am safe
Oh one's family always family yeah give
him a little peek
he still in there yeah whoo yes yes yes
yes I think he went to the balcony yes
yes be quiet though like I would crouch
take your time with this such a loud
lock Crouch there's a window there you
can see if you're I think I don't know
can you come in here uh yes but just
don't let him know you're in here can
you close the door I don't know go try
it
he's not a dude is he is you're gonna
have to do something you're not
accomplishing anything by oh [ __ ]
ocean oh no he doesn't know where he's
playing how do you know cuz the music
didn't kick in I can't shut it
don't worry about showing it just uh
yeah just check around quietly damn you
oh wait wait wait how do you know please
don't come in here okay you're gonna
hate this but if he does come in here
there's a shotgun
did you see it said there's a shotgun in
here make sure you grab that if
everywhere it is it's next to the door I
think oh [ __ ] I hear I'm sorry oh my god
we can tell his footsteps me
I don't know you're still better I don't
know
stay crouched I think it's quite
you told me you didn't know well I do I
don't I actually can't read that I'm too
scared
wait where's the shotgun right there
next to the door oh I see it okay there
you go you probably know it's do that
right he pointed out stuff you want to
die wait [ __ ] why why would you do that
[Music]
something under the bed
I forgot what do I do
use oh it's broken oh he's not here so
you could probably just explore the rest
is room quickly you won't be low five
you would kill you okay I think I'm good
honestly just I feel pretty good hold on
he's not here read this just to make
sure there's nothing important oh here
you go perfect hit the dog head reliefs
they can't get out of house living room
grandfather clock that's when we got the
one we got book in the recreation room
the dissection room in the basement so a
book there's another note behind that
door right there you could check if he's
not in here
yeah it's just talking about how people
turn what's just hide frozen okay
there's a book in here so quite what
you're saying no no no so the recreation
was the one next to you at the bar in
the billiard table
the one where he keeps coming out yeah
the one near where you where the tape
was that trash can so remember the
shotgun room locks up once you lift the
shotgun off the thing so if you get
there you're safe if you get there and
pick up the shack on you're safe
why because you can't get to you oh
right so are you saying just run there
you might as well you've got the
replacement shotgun well I mean if you
can stealth I hear well yeah if you
could sneak you might as well just wait
it out that's cause for concern
so I mean if he's on the balcony he goes
oh we're leaving right yeah [ __ ] he
might be out here he's probably here
shut up yeah oh wait wait you're here
you might as well there's a football
helmet right behind you I think there's
something inside it
whoops nope never mind you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god check out second wait
oh [ __ ] do you have room to pay yeah you
do yeah I do it won't close once you
pick up I don't know if you're looking
at it correctly oh I see being paranoid
but you did get the right shotgun right
I have a working one okay cuz it says
broken shotgun and this one says mp3
seven okay so now what so there's you
know there's a dog head up in that room
you just came from the billiard room
yeah and there's one of the dissection
room in the basement right you might as
well dissection room which way I mean
you could just do the recreation room
while you're here while you're in the
recreation and you could do miss the one
I just came from yeah but there's no
guarantees up you could do me as tape
while you're up there as well oh my god
he's always in there yeah what do I do
with the shotgun is that for him or do
you think that's for like normal
situations I would save it it's good
against cuz I'm mad at health and I'm in
yellow he's you can make a helper I can
should I
no harm I hate this guy so much Chris
sworn there was something on that shelf
maybe was the football I don't know
yeah use these windows sooner what do
you mean in the recreation room to your
left
Oh might be in there don't sound like it
but yeah check this out okay so you can
do the tape there and doesn't make noise
well it'll pause for each time there's
also my [ __ ] baby heart yeah she made
you a mixtape am I supposed to do
something no it's your wife by the way
not girlfriend Mia winter is Ethan
winters wait yeah
2017-19 even if you find this I know I
can't expect anything from you not after
what happened to what I did but I just
want you to know that wasn't me I don't
I don't know what happened
there's so much that you need to know
there you are you gave us quite a scare
young lady please take the control okay
oh and me yeah I played this in VR oh
yeah
I remember to hide that was weird what
you just said that was that Marguerite
he died I need to hide why time played
this in VR done to deserve this
except open this is the only and feed
outside of that you're fresh to the game
right yeah that and there's this one
part with a girls doll that I also
played in VR she's going here she went
in the right room that's where you need
to go before you go this one well tough
love that she's taping us it's very
where am I supposed to hide
I know you and Zoey are flock I know you
were scheming
I think God don't know what you want to
do with that boy Ethan oh god please
don't come out here
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't think she's gonna find me
oh go now go now she's under oh I know
yes you can go now
where am I going try to do this real
quick oh she's too close yeah okay just
go wait her out in the hallway behind
that thing I'm fairly certain she would
have come to your side if you didn't do
that I could be wrong but you're safe
oh yeah here I'll feed you to my babies
and fertilize the garden with what was
left [ __ ] she's mean
so yeah once she goes into the room
you're writing this book and do the
puzzle shut up we open our home we open
our hearts and what do you do oh my god
even though I've like done this I'm so
stressed you got it
yeah okay so this is spiders spider-man
oh that kind of looks like it horizontal
flip would probably do it right
that's [ __ ]
good lord
wait okay it's still me so I go into the
safety hole mm-hmm
god bless the safety hulk-like wife like
husband what do you mean oh right we're
not married
yeah you are we are told you that during
the intro of the tape and said Mia
winters you're Ethan winters oh I
thought we were like girlfriend and
boyfriend pretty sure you marry that's
why I lessen the winters
I guess I'm Ethan winters where am I
crouched down right here
she loves you she wants us to be a
family god damn it
okay I think the people are you crazy
[ __ ] [ __ ] where you going lady get
closer to them
we love you
[Music]
oh she saw me what's weird was that
there's a valve to you right no where do
you think you're going
did you see that there's that valve
under there
yeah mental take a mental note of that
all right god I hope this guy isn't in
here cuz that's how you can get one of
the dog had keys in this room in a book
they said great
I remember that I have to get this save
is that what that's doing a question I
think so but I'm not positive I haven't
saved in a saving machine tape recorder
whenever yeah I think it's an obviously
know that's a loading thing I don't know
if that's a safe thing
either way you're in good shape you saw
the healthy you can use
are you anxious right now a little bit
cuz I don't want that guy to be there
when I come out at the tape it's also
like honestly just a little cruel
because no he's not going to like I said
time freezes when you do stuff like this
pretty sure I'm this difficulty so on
the hardest difficulty they come in the
same room pretty positive you add many
notes
do you have a certain amount of saves
good question I thought so I think Sean
Luke's the only one I know that's played
through the whole thing on the bad house
dang being a producer games about
correct I don't know if I would have the
guts to do such a thing
it sounds really fun but also in the
garage fight the key isn't just out on
the table it's also in a locker in the
garage so you have to find the key to
the locker first while Jack is chasing
you and then get the key out of there
it's a car oh so just all around things
are jumbled up and harder it's like an
arranged mo what did they do to you oh I
thought that was Jack's voice where is
the book yeah
looking for a book in I have to read to
get ski whip yes okay cool
the other ones in the dissection room
it's alright let's [ __ ] [ __ ] off of
this area cuz we don't need any more
right we're done well jeez there's a
spider key whatever that door is turn at
either just spider no yeah sorry there's
a block spider door so you'll be back
here oh right
that [ __ ] here
alright so should I I should go in my
hidey hole correct I know you're here
put the dog head in okay and then yeah
and then go to either saver in laundry
room or the safety hole god damn it
mary's I'm sorry what you can also get
rid of that tape now in the save box
okay just so you don't forget next time
next time you're going into the basement
oh yeah forgot this course here now
right there save room save hole should
we save yeah put the item let's get the
items you want then save so you don't do
it the beginning in next episode
actually no do you want to get it no
just save cuz that'll jog your memory at
the beginning of next episode I think
like what items you need and stuff I
would just keep it like this oh you got
rid of it
scorpion key so I don't think it's like
resonable one where they just
disintegrate or whatever say there's no
more use I think you actually stopped
using it
are there more doors with it though I
honestly don't remember I'm just gonna
keep it for now yeah I mean I'm like I
feel like I need a beer I'm like really
it's just an AHA okay cool this is like
very amnesia currently like when I used
to play amnesia I used to have to a lot
enough time before I went to bed to have
a beer and like
relax because I couldn't sleep after
playing it because it stressed me out so
badly and like this was a hell of an
episode well what do you think in the
game it's fantastic it's scary as hell
they do such a good job at like making
me upset intense in every situation the
dad is like such a piece of [ __ ] and
he's like so in my face everywhere and
he's I could hear him I can see him I
was awful like I mean he's just they've
done a tremendous job and it's just I
mean it's one of the best games I've
played so far like it's really good it's
really really good cool I need a nap
people are watching this game spots if
people watching this when it first was
up game spots extra life marathon will
be going so yeah I'm gonna be at this
point you would have joined two days ago
when they released I think the UK or
Australia is straight very now but if
you're watching this after extra life
it's done either way we'll see you next
week and thanks for watching as always
thanks for watching bye
oh I need a nap gonna be your beard
enough